foreign
quick service restaurant hamburger chain
we have about 7 000 locations in more
than 30 countries Wendy's is a company
that has Innovation built into our DNA
within about 1970 when Dave Thomas
introduced the first modern
drive-through changing the qsr industry
as we know it today we're focused on
global growth and digital acceleration
and with that we're becoming a true
digital technology enabled company our
strategy at Wendy's is to build a
centralized trusted source of Truth we
leverage bigquery for our data lake
house which makes our information
available in relevant time and easily
accessible for our business to use it
provides us a really rich foundation for
us to tackle a variety of AI and data
use cases our most exciting use case
which is using generative AI in our
drive-through in natural language we
have over three and a half million
monthly active users in our loyalty
program so we needed the scalability of
a platform like bigquery and so we
pulled our CDP out of
any other platform and put it into
bigquery so that we could build on
things like Customer Loyalty we could
build product Affinity groups and build
greater personalization we could then
start to understand what third party
data how weather impacts our consumer
buying behaviors we use things like
traffic data and competitive Landscapes
to determine where the prime locations
to build new restaurants are we use
weather data and events data to help us
with preparing our inventory to ensure
we have enough inventory and hey you may
have heard of those super fund Reggie
Bush commercials that we have that's
because we have the third party data
that tells us 30 percent of our customer
base our football fans I think we've
just begun to scratch the surface of the
AI use cases that we'll see and I'm
super excited for Wendy's to lead that
Journey we do use voice AI in our drive
through this is a platform that Wendy's
calls fresh Ai and if you haven't done
so I encourage you to go check out the
Showcase the there's plenty of use cases
that we're testing out probably the one
that I'm the most excited about has to
do with solving a problem in the data
space Wendy's is currently testing
multiple approaches using generative AI
on top of our trusted data sources to
help solve that problem but think about
that I mean the possibilities are
endless when we get that right
Innovation is built into our DNA as a
company I think our people are what make
the difference we have fantastic
Partnerships such as the partnership
that we have with Google we have a
really strong Business and Technology
leadership team we have a
forward-looking board of directors who
is always challenging us and our CIO is
known for doing The Impossibles but
equally important we have a really
strong relationship with our franchisees
so we chose Google Cloud for multiple
reasons we needed the you know compute
power so it not only does it have the
compute power but the offerings that we
needed to make our business successful
things like the power of vertex AI allow
alongside of bigquery let us perform
things like sentiment analysis on social
media Impressions that we're listening
for Google is also an innovator in Ai
and because of this we know that we can
deliver an elevated experience for our
customers in the drive-throughs think
about this for a second this is a
Monumental task that we're performing
together
our menu complexity is enormous there's
something more than 200 billion ways
that you can order a Dave's double that
is amazing right I have no idea yes 200
billion and the complexities are being
solved with what we're doing together
add in the noise and the issues that you
have with a drive-through speaker it's
huge it's a huge task that we're doing
over 75 percent of Wendy's customers
choose the drive-through as they're
ordering preference so we have to get
this right but we're confident with
Google being our partner to get there
the power of AI really allows us to
re-imagine what we do how we do it and
who we do it for in virtually all parts
of an Enterprise your data is your most
valuable and your most differentiated
asset
it's the key to unlock the power of AI
for your business the solution is to
understand data and AI in duality
the solution is to build on an AI data
Foundation to make AI easily available
to all your data practitioners and to
make your data easily accessible to AI
models
today we are announcing the ability to
access vertex ai's Foundation model
directly from bigquery with just a
single statement you can connect a
bigquery table with a large language
model in vertex
and you can tune and use prompts with
all of your big query data
this allows you to use gen AI
capabilities such as text analysis on
your data or generate new attributes for
your table data in bigquery bringing AI
to your data also means bringing the
teams together while working on AI and
beta in a shared environment
and we are excited to announce the
preview of our brand new and super
awesome bigquery Studio
bigquery studio is now a place where
data engineering analytics and machine
learning can be brought together on one
environment
Google cloud is built with the leading
AI models
and duet AI is our collaborative
experience that helps you work on gcp
I am thrilled to announce the preview of
duetei in bigquery
duet AI can assist you with writing SQL
and python code and allowing you to
focus more on logic and outcomes it also
suggests code in real time and it
generates full functions and code blocks
for you
I am fired up to announce two at AI for
looker
allows to do two conversational data
analysis in natural language
duet AI looker can automatically
generate dashboards and reports by you
telling local the goals of your analysis
to at Ai and looker can generate
Google's lights for you so you can take
you to the next meeting and discuss your
findings with your colleagues imagine
what is possible in your future with the
ability to unlock the potential that
your data holds we believe that your
data is the key to unlock your AI
transformation
to continuously solve for what's coming
next and to innovate in your industry
and this is why we are building with so
much passion Google's data and AI Cloud
for you
[Music]